Hey everybody, welcome
to the content video
going over section 1
.1, what did I just say,
section 7.14 of your textbook.
And actually what we're going to
be doing in the next couple of
content videos regarding pandas is
jumping between section 1.1, I
keep saying 1, 7.141 and 7.142.
Mostly because, and we're really
just going to be bouncing around
within those sections because
these sections are kind of large
and they do cover a wide variety
of topics and so we're going to
break these down into different
subjects and and in what things
you need to know for pandas and
using pandas and data frames so
first kind of what we'll start
with is talking about what a data
frame is and it's really a simple
way to work with larger data sets
in python but it also allows you
to handle things like missing
data in a way that doesn't just
completely ignore its existence
It allows greater manipulation
and easier number crunching. So if
you wanted to do things like
calculate mean, standard deviation,
percentiles, things like that.
And what makes data frames cool is
that they're based on NumPy array
optimization. So that's what it says
here at the top of your textbook,
which means that they run pretty
quick and they're great for handling
large amounts of data. So, what
we're going to do is we're going
to talk about a data frame versus
a series in this content video,
but to do that we'll jump over into
our VS Code code space and we'll
get started. So, what we're going
to be doing with Pandas is using
something called a notebook, which
you may have used in other classes
that talked about Python before.
Notebooks are very, very
similar to Python files, except
that a notebook will have
two different types of
cells that you can have, a
markdown cell or a code cell.
Markdown is just where you
can type in plain text. So
this is pandas and pandas,
probably call them data frames.
And then I would hit, oops, this
is the, that's the Python cell.
This is the markdown cell. Then
I would hit this little checkbox
and then this turns into just a
little title or just regular text.
And then if you wanted a code cell, you
could do something like
4i range 10 print I.
And then you just run this code
off to the left and it will run
for you as it would in a regular
Python environment. The only
difference is that in a notebook
you'll run things cell by cell.
And so that makes it different
than what we've been doing up to
this point in the semester. So
I'm going to get rid of this cell.
And what we're going to do is we are
actually going to start
by importing pandas.
And we'll import it as pd.
That's pretty common.
And then we will also read in a data
set that we're going to be using
for this unit, which is the
titanic.csv. you should be able to
access that no problem from canvas
you just download it and then click
and drag it into your code space
and it should be available to you
there so what we're going to do is
we are going to read in the data
from our titanic.csv and normally
what we do is maybe we'd say file
equals open and then do file
.readlines but this time we're going to
use pandas because they have a built
-in function with pandas that allows
you to read an entire data set
in from a CSV to a data frame. So
let's make a variable to store this
data frame. I'll call it Titanic
data frame and set that or assign
it the value of PD dot read CSV.
And then I need to grab the
exact file path here of my
Titanic data set. So I'm going
to right click on it and copy
the path. I'm not going to
get the relative path because
for some reason that was
breaking for me earlier. So I'm
just going to read CSV, paste
that whole thing in here.
And then maybe normally to
it, we'd say is let's print
Titanic data frame, but we
actually don't need to use
the type the print function
in a notebook. If we just
type in Titanic data frame,
and then run this code cell,
we actually should just see it
print out the object for us.
Also, if you are, I'm just realizing
that I've already set up this
notebook to run with my Python 3.12.
If you're getting any kind of issue
running this notebook, if it's just
typing in as like white text or
something like that, then you should
connect it to your Python kernel. And
it should kind of prompt you for
these options as you're going through.
So if you are trying to run this,
you'll click on, you know, it's
a Jupyter notebook, and then run
it on whatever version of Python
you're running on your VS Code
code space, which should be 3.12.
And then just let me or one
of the TAs know if you can't
get it running, and then
we'll help you out with that.
Okay, so here's our Titanic data
frame. So what we're looking at here
is all, it kind of looks just like
if we had a spreadsheet open in front
of us, right? We can see we've got
columns, we've got rows, and we've
got all of this data, that now we
can do something with and what well
there's a lot of options of what
we could do with it now but what
I'll kind of do for now is I just want
to see a little bit more information
about it and there's this really
really great function called info
exactly what we might want to run
or use. So I'll just run a Titanic
for data frame dot info in a new
cell and I get a ton of information
about this data frame. So for example,
it is a data frame. It has 891
entries. There are 12 columns and here
are the columns. We have information
like passenger ID, survived,
passenger class, the name, sex, age
of our passengers, if they had a
sibling or spouse, a parent or child,
the ticket number that they had,
how much they paid for their fare,
their cabin number, and which port
they embarked from. Now, I know a
little bit more about this data
set because I've read up on it, but
this gives us a ton of information
even right here. So for example,
the survived column here, we can
see that it's an integer. And so you
might ask yourself, why is survived
an integer? It seems like they
would either be a true or a false
right but then we can maybe look here
and we can see survived is actually
zero or one pretty much through
our entire data frame and so it is
kind of a binary true false variable
there so this helps us to know
a little bit more about our data
before we start doing anything
really with it we could also see just
our columns by typing in data frame
columns and here are our columns.
We also could learn a little
bit more about our rows
by typing in index.
I'm gonna comment out this line
and just run it on the index.
So you can see we've got,
it starts at zero, stops at 891.
Also one more thing that this
dataframe.info function does for
us is it actually tells us how
many non-null values we have in
our data set. So for example,
we're missing quite a few ages.
Here we can see that in
all the other columns,
we've got 891 entries,
except age has 714. So we're
missing the ages of
several of our passengers.
Also, we're missing the cabins
for a number of our passengers
as well. And then for some
reason, we're missing two of the
ports that our passengers
embarked from. And if you've seen
Titanic, you probably know that
a couple people just jumped onto
the boat last minute, so they
wouldn't have an embarked port.
That's a joke, a dumb joke.
Okay, so let's keep going.
Another common function that you'll use
with a data frame is the head function.
So if I have TitanicDataFrame.head,
what this does is it allows me to
see the first five rows of my data
frame. And this is helpful because
we don't always want to see the
entirety of the data frame, nor
do we want to see you know a huge
preview of the whole thing sometimes
we just want to get a snapshot of
what that looks like you can put
into the head function as many rows
as you want and it will print those
out for you so that is a really
really good one similarly there's
another function called tail which
does the same exact thing but does
it for the end of your data frame
and then another helpful
one just to learn more
about your data is going
to be the shape function
which doesn't need parentheses
so this tells me I've got
891 rows 12 columns so some
helpful syntax there okay let's
add another markdown cell and
I'm going to talk just briefly
about the difference between
a series and a data frame.
Okay so let's say for example I
wanted to pull out all of the ages
of my passengers in my Titanic data
frame. So I'll make a new variable
and I'll call it ages and I will
assign it the value of Titanic
data frame and then the way that you
reference a column in a data frame
is by using brackets and then
putting the name of the column in
there so and it has to be spelled
exactly the same so I usually just go
up here and actually copy and
paste rather than try and spell it
because I'm a horrible speller and
inevitably I will spell something
wrong so let's now just output our
ages so here we can see it's a kind
of single column I guess you could
say it looks like a list right
this looks familiar but note how our
values still have an index number
they're assigned some kind of a
value on the side there so if I
was to for example print out the
type of ages remember type just tells
me what data type my variable is
and I print that out you can see
that the this is a pandas series
so it's not a list it's not a data
frame it's a series. A series acts
a lot like a list, but here's a key
difference. So if I just pulled
all the values from my data frame
and put it into a Python list,
anywhere where I was missing values,
which remember we were missing a
number of values in our age column,
anywhere where we had missing
values those would not exist in our
default or our built-in Python list,
whereas in a series we can still
handle that missing data and do
something with it and so my series
will kind of hold the places
of the missing ages and if I uh
let's see let me go back to just
outputting ages yeah and you can see
actually here's a great example
so uh in our 888 position you can
see that the age is not a number
it's a missing value um but we still
keep that position in our series
so hopefully that makes sense.
Whoops,
I just hit undo, but what I
really wanted to do is redo.
So print type
ages.
We'll output that. Panda series, perfect.
And then if we wanted to instead
pull a subset of our
data frame and keep that
as a data frame, what I
could do is I could say
subset and assign the value
of Titanic data frame.
This time I'm going to use a double
bracket and here's why because
I'm pulling out multiple values
so I'll pull out name I believe
that's yeah name and then let's
also grab I don't know sex and age.
Double brackets means that I will
get a data frame from my data frame.
So now if I, let's just output subset,
it should look like a
data frame, which it does,
it's got indexes, it's
got rows and columns,
but now if I was to print
the type of my subset,
we should see class pandas data
frame. And I believe if we just,
you know, there's some brackets
over here on our first example here,
that age right here, even
though it's just a single column
would still be a data frame so
again hopefully some of this
is making sense to you guys
but that's going to wrap up
everything for this content video
so So thank you for watching.